une épaisse colonne de fumée s'élève
dans le ciel de kaboul à nouveau la
capitale afghane vient d'être frappé par
un attentat
et cette fois ci c'est l'un des plus
hauts dirigeants du pays qui était visé
le premier vice président amrous la
salle et un kamikaze se serait fait
exploser près de son convoi alors qu'il
se rendait à son bureau
sortie quasi indemne de l'attaqué il a
rapidement publié une vidéo rassurante
sur facebook un certain nombre de mes
courageux gardes du corps ont été
blessées et ont été évacués vers
l'hôpital des services de renseignement
mon plus jeune fils abdullah qui était
avec moi pendant la taxe va bien mon
fils et moi avons subi quelques brûlures
mineures au visage et ma main a été
légèrement blessé car la puissance de
l'explosion était très forte et a fait
fondre les vitres du véhicule
malheureusement il y a aussi des
dommages matériels
un certain nombre de civils ont été
blessés le lieu où l'explosion s'est
produite
était une rue étroite cet attentat
témoigne aussi de la violence
persistante dans le pays malgré des
négociations qui se poursuivent entre le
gouvernement et les talibans de nouveaux
pourparlers doivent démarrer bientôt au
qatar après avoir été reporté à
plusieurs reprises en cause notamment
des désaccords autour d'un échange de
prisonniers
aujourd'hui presque achevée un contexte
d'instabilité qui met également en
exergue les difficultés d'application de
l'accord entre les taliban et washington
le texte signé à doha en février dernier
prévoit notamment un retrait des soldats
américains en 2021 selon la maison
blanche le président américain devrait
faire une annonce dans ce sens
rapidement